to be honest it's quite difficult um to
put it into words obviously
there was a racist incident on the pitch
um i felt that it was the right thing to
you know to report this and and be
honest and open about it to raise
awareness
and the aftermath of that was something
i couldn't have ever
imagined would happen um obviously i've
never been
at that point i've never been in the
public eye before
i just got thousands of thousands of
comments
flooding in um racial comments
um comments obviously about women's
football my gender about the way i
looked
um and it sent me into a very very dark
place it was awful
but what what on earth were these people
complaining about
well a lot of them were saying that i
was um
i was doing it to almost get myself
ahead in life you know for
a bit of click bait um which is just
completely
completely bizarre to me um that i was
making it up playing the race card
um someone said to me someone actually
said to me you know i i'm not actually
um black enough to to be racially abused
and that my skin was actually too light
so i had it the other way around as well
i had
you know monkey images sent to me all
sorts
honestly i couldn't he said some of the
stuff is not appropriate to say on live
television it was it was just horrendous
i i i'm struggling with the idea that
someone can complain
of you playing the race card when you're
reporting
incidents of racism i mean i'm getting
an impression
that the that the aftermath of the
racism
perhaps had a more significant and
long-lasting effect on you than that
which took place on the pitch
yeah oh 100 because i think
when you are racially abused um
i think if you're you know if you're
racially abusing me you're racially
abusing
everybody who is of you know black
heritage
asian heritage whatever it may be so you
almost feel
absolutely it's awful and it's it's
incredibly upsetting and it's wrong
but you don't feel like it's so personal
if that makes sense but
um some of the comments i got were
definitely more personal about me
my appearance um about my character
as well so that stuff is what really
really
got to me that i wasn't prepared for i i
take it then that there is little that
followed you know the missing of the
penalties in terms of the abuse that
that that surprises you i mean you you
tweeted this the other day
bored of the it's a small minority
nonsense that may be but they're very
loud there's a lot about our fan culture
which is a disgrace i mean what needs
what needs to happen among england fans
because this is not the first time we've
seen this of course
no and it was awful honestly when i woke
up um
on monday morning don't get me wrong i
was as gutted as the next england fan
um at the result but when i woke up
immediately you know i felt a sense of
pride i was proud of our boys
you know they brought so much joy to me
personally into the country
and then to see
to see that that these young boys
receive such
awful abuse and you know what as soon as
those three boys missed the penalty i
knew what was to come
and that is the sad thing it's so sad
um and i think the only way
the only way we can move forward is to
drown them out because as i said in that
tweet
that it may be a small minority but they
are so so loud at the minute
they are so loud and they are getting
away with it and
and i think the only thing we can do is
that there is strength in numbers and i
think there are more people
who are kind of who want to support i
mean look at marcus rashford's
mural in the town where he's from i mean
all it took was for one person to step
forward
you know cover that awful abuse up and
put one love heart note on it and look
how many people followed
and i think that is so important because
kindness and bravery is a contagious
thing it really is contagious
so i think more people need to make that
step
and then hundreds will follow and i
think that's the only way that we can
drown them out